I have been asked for some intuition as
to why let's say a to the minus B is
equal to one over a to the B and before
I give you the intuition I want you to
just realize that this really is a
definition the I don't know the inventor
of mathematics you know wasn't one
person it was you know a convention that
arose but they did they define this and
they define this for the reasons that
I'm going to show you well the what I'm
going to show you is one of the reasons
and we'll see that this is a good
definition because once you learn to
exponent rules all of the other exponent
rules stay consistent when you for
negative exponents and when you raise
something to the zeroth power so let's
take the positive exponents
those are pretty intuitive I think so
the positive exponents so you have a to
the 1 a squared a cubed a to the fourth
what's a to the 1 a to the 1 we said was
a and then to get to a squared what did
we do we multiply it by a right a
squared is just a times a and then to
get to a cubed what did we do we
multiplied by a again and then to get to
a to the fourth what do we do we
multiplied by a again or the other way
you could imagine is when you decrease
the exponent what are we doing we are
multiplying by 1 over a or dividing by a
it's similarly decrease again you're
dividing by a and go from a squared to a
to the first you're dividing by a so
let's use this progression to figure out
what a to the 0 is so this is the first
hard one so a to the 0 so you're the
you're the inventor the founding mother
of mathematics and you need to define
what a to the 0 is and you know maybe
it's 17 maybe it's some you know maybe
it's pi I don't know you it's up to you
to decide what a 2-0 is but wouldn't it
be nice if a to the 0 retained this
pattern that every time you decrease the
exponent you're dividing by a right so
if you're going from a to the first to a
to the zero would it be nice if we just
divided by a
so let's do that so if we go from a to
the first which is just a and divided by
a right so we're just going to go we're
just going to divide it by a what is a
divided by a well it's just one so
that's where the definition or that's
one of the intuitions behind why
something to the zeroth power is equal
to one because when you take that that
number and you divide it by itself one
more time you just get one so that's
pretty reasonable but now let's go into
the negative domain so what should a to
the negative one equal a to the negative
one well once again it's nice if we can
retain this pattern where every time we
decrease the exponent we're dividing by
a so let's divide by a again so 1 over a
so we're going to take a to the zero and
divide it by a a to the zero divided by
a a to the zero is one so what's 1
divided by a it's 1 over a and let's do
it one more time and then I think you're
going to get the pattern well I think
you probably already got the pattern
what's a to the minus 2 well we want you
know it'd be silly now to to change this
pattern every time we decrease the
exponent we're dividing by a so to go
from a to the minus 1 to a to the minus
2 let's just divide by a again and what
do we get we get if you take 1 over a
and divide by a you get 1 over a squared
and you could just keep doing this
pattern all the way to the left and you
would get a to the minus B is equal to 1
over a to the B hopefully that gave you
a little intuition as to why well first
of all you know the big mystery is well
you know something to a zeroth power why
does that equal one first keep in mind
that that's just a definition someone
decided that it should be equal one but
they had a good reason and the good
reason was they wanted to keep this
pattern going and that's the same reason
why they defined negative exponents in
this way and what's extra cool about it
is not only does it retain this pattern
of when you decrease exponents you're
dividing by a or when you're increasing
exponents you're multiplying by a but as
you'll see in the exponent rules videos
all of the exponent rules hold all of
the exponent rules are consistent with
this definition of something to the
zeroth power and this definition of
something to the negative
our hopefully that didn't confuse you
and gave you a little bit of intuition
and demystified something that frankly
is quite mystifying the first time you
learn it